julia roberts stars opposite of jennifer  aniston in the new movie  Mother's Day - of kids career keeps me  kissing who should I make him et caught  up with Anacin at the film's premiere in  Hollywood where she admits she was  nervous working with her co-star so is  it true that even though you've known  Julia Roberts forever you were still a  little intimidated when you were working  with her is that true yes yeah why cuz  it's Julia Roberts oh my gosh I mean  it's a different thing when you know you  get to sort of work with them and then  you're doing what you both do together  you know what I mean so I mean I think I  even flubbed in the first I believe take  and called her Julia instead of I saw  that in the at the end of the movies it  shows the outtakes oh you do do the hell  I like that they really sent that one  home Mother's Day hits theaters on April  29th